imaginez que vous n'êtes plus en fait
sale imaginez que vous êtes au milieu de
la savane
il y à cent mille ans et vous allez
devoir prendre des risques pour aller à
la recherche de nourriture pour votre
clan une intuition ne pas vraiment
l'instinct peut-être un signal chimique
un signal hormonal les hormones qui
s'occupe de l'énergie de notre corps
sont au plus bas
l'insuline qui s'occupe de faire rentrer
le sucre dans les muscles et la leptine
qui gèrent nos réserves de graisse sont
très basses et c'est parce que vous
ressentez ces signaux qu'il risque d'y
avoir des conséquences les femmes vont
arrêter de pouvoir être enceinte
elles ne pourront plus se reproduire
notre clan ne pourra plus se reproduire
les enfants risquent de mourir de faim
les hommes ne pourront plus aller
chasser et votre peuple risque de
s'éteindre
les hormones sont un système de
communication et de messagerie
absolument formidable dont tous les
êtres vivants en sont dotés
je suis un endocrinologue médecins
spécialistes des hormones et je
n'essaierai d'endoctriner personnes ce
soir
les hormones sont fabriqués par des
cellules spécialisées les cellules
endocrines il y a des glandes dont le
sait leur fonction particulière il ya
également des hormones fabriqués dans
d'autres organes comme l'intestin par
exemple et ses hormones
elles vont avoir un rôle tout au long de
notre vie dès la naissance les
contractions de l'utérus vont être
déclenchées par l'ocytocine et au moment
où la femme va ressentir les douleurs
les plus violentes qui existe elle va
avoir la l'ocytocine va avoir une autre
action extraordinaire parce que c'est
grâce à elle que la mer va créer
un lien avec son bébé ce bébé va se
mettre à téter de la prolactine va être
produite qui va permettre de produire le
lait et en même temps cette pro latine
elle va inhiber les hormones sexuelles
ainsi la maman sera uniquement centré
sur son enfant puis l'enfant va grandir
sous l'impulsion de l'hormone de
croissance évidemment il ya un moment il
ya un grand pic l'adolescence 30 cm en
quelques mois et vous vous retrouvez à
acheter trois paires de chaussures à
votre adolescent
et puis c'est pas facile pour lui d'être
à l'aise dans ce corps qui change si
vite sans compter si vous rajoutez
quelques microgrammes de stéroïdes
les hormones sexuelles la cne les poils
qui pousse les organes génitaux qui
change les cheveux qui deviennent gras
les odeurs corporelles et les pulsions
sexuelles
et c'est en plus le moment de la vie où
l'eau devient le plus soumis à sa
dopamine l'hormone du plaisir mais je
vais y revenir
il ya parfois des moments dans la vie où
justement il ya des déséquilibres
hormonaux
je suis sûr qu'au temps de vous
connecter ces des femmes qui quelques
jours avant leurs règles sont plus
fatigués ont des douleurs se plaignent
sont déprimés irritable c'est juste un
déséquilibre entre les estrogènes et la
progestérone
on appelle cela le syndrome prémenstruel
mais parfois il y à plus grave il ya de
vraies maladies
laissez moi vous raconter l'histoire
d'elena que j'ai vu il ya quelques mois
elena elle est rentrée dans mon cabinet
les yeux exorbités le coup gonfler un
peu tremblante son mari l'accompagnent
il a l'air un peu suspicieux et sombre
elle me raconte ses tachycardie son
amaigrissement sa diarrhée elle me tend
ces examens elle son mari fait une
remarque et ça y est ils commencent à se
disputer
je leur dis stop ne divorçaient pas tout
de suite
c'est juste une hyperthyroïdie
des médicaments et quelques mois plus
tard je vous rassure
elena et son mari sont toujours en
couple enfin je crois
je peux aussi vous raconter l'histoire
de thérèse thérèse c'est une jeune femme
musicienne brillante
un jour elle est fatiguée elle va voir
son médecin c'est pas grave vous êtes un
peu déprimée elle prend 20 kg il lui
donne des antidépresseurs elle reprend
encore 20 kg et c'est son ventre sur son
ventre apparaissent des vergetures
énorme des poils se met à pousser sur
son visage de l'acné elle et devient
vraiment mélancolique et c'est l'hôpital
psychiatrique jusqu'à ce qu'un jour un
jeune médecin l'a déshabillé ludisme et
madame vous avez une maladie de cushing
c'est dans votre hypophyse elle a été
opérée et maintenant elle est
complètement guéri ce sont en fait ces
hormones du cortisol qui était déréglé
la nature nous a dotés de deux glande
juste au dessus des reins qu'on appelle
les surrénales c'est elle qui nous
permettent de réagir face au danger elle
joue le rôle sur l'amygdale notamment
vous voyez un rhinocéros up vos
surrénales vont engendrer une bouffée
d'adrénaline et vous allez pouvoir
réagir vite vous réfugier et puis elle
fabrique aussi d'autres hormones ce
fameux cortisol le matin vous en
fabriquer beaucoup pour avoir beaucoup
d'énergie pour aller chasser et cueillir
enfin du moins c'était à ça qu'elle
servait au départ et puis après fur et à
mesure de la journée le taux de cortisol
diminue le soir on est plus fatigué on
peut dormir et passer une nuit sereine
mais imaginez que toute la journée on
vous donne des ordres répété en vous
fait des remarques incessantes vous
attendez un métro qui ne vient pas
comment voulez vous que votre taux de
cortisol diminue le soir mais dans notre
cerveau nous avons d'autres hormones les
neuro hormones les hormones du bien-être
ces hormones
en 1 4 l'ocytocine dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure
celle du lien de l'attachement de la
maman avec son bébé
c'est cette même ocytocine qui permet de
créer le lien avec ses amis de créer
l'empathie de reconnaître que son proche
est heureux et de partager son bonheur
avec lui et aussi de s'apercevoir que sa
voisine est un peu triste et qu'il faut
la console et de les endorphines
ce sont les hormones de résistance à la
douleur
celles qui permettent aux marathoniens
qui était puisée au 40e kilomètre de
courir au fond pour arriver jusqu'à la
ligne et pouvoir la franchir
3 la sérotonine l'hormone du bonheur
celle qui nous donne de l'optimisme qui
nous donne envie d'avancer
parfois certains gens sont un peu
déprimé et on leur donne des médicaments
pour booster la sérotonine
vous savez le prozac comme si le bonheur
pouvait se trouver dans une pilule et 4
j'y viens
la dopamine la fameuse hormone du
plaisir
celle que l'on produit lorsqu'on a un
long baiser langoureux
celle que l'on a lorsqu'on mange un
chocolat
du coup on va en prendre un deuxième
mais en fait la deuxième fois le plaisir
est un peu moins alors j'en prends un
troisième
c'est un peu moins alors je vais
regarder des vidéos youtube une première
une deuxième et c'est comme ça que je
devient accro mais d'ailleurs notre
société de consommation marche un peu
sur ce système là j'achète une belle
voiture
je vais vite non je suis contente et hop
je vais reprendre ma voiture et aller
toujours plus vite parce que la deuxième
fois j'ai un peu moins de plaisir et je
voudrai toujours avoir la dopamine
ou alors je vais m'acheter une paire de
chaussures et je suis heureuse d'avoir
cette paire de chaussures
mais c'est ce plaisir ne dure que
quelques instants et je voudrais en
avoir une deuxième et donc la société
l'industrie a bien compris comment nous
faire dépenser
et nous faire continuer à consommer nos
hormones nos hormones comme serait-elle
perturbé parce que j'y viens à ces
fameux perturbateurs endocriniens
on en parle toute la journée il y a dans
les cosmétiques dans les plastiques dans
les pesticides
alors on les cherche tous sur nos
applications et on est très fiers de
sortir de notre de notre épicier bio
mais on retrouve sur nos smartphones le
soir et on rentre à la maison et on fait
regarder une petite vidéo à nos enfants
et pourtant l'ocytocine que va sécréter
enfants est-ce qu'elle va être de la
même qualité que lorsque je vais lui
raconter une histoire ou que je vais
jouer à un jeu de société avec elle est
ce que mon pic d'ocytocine sera d'aussi
bonne qualité que lorsque je vais aller
visiter ma grand mère et lui tenir la
main
ces neurones il ne faut pas oublier
elles sont fabriquées dans notre cerveau
primitif mais au dessus il y à notre
cortex
c'est lui qui génèrent nos pensées c'est
lui le créateur de notre conscience et
c'est grâce à lui que nous pouvons avoir
la liberté
en effet si nous nous laissons aux
primés par toutes ces hormones et par
tous ces comportements répétés et que
nous perdons la capacité de faire des
efforts pour essayer de retrouver notre
liberté notre libre arbitre
ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains
alors nous serons seulement sous
influence hormonale
[Applaudissements]